on Thursdays bonus show we talked about
Fox News commentator Sean Hannity being
forced to take a few days off from his
show because advertisers started pulling
ads off of his program and one of the
reasons that advertisers have been
bailing on Hannity is that he pushed
this debunked conspiracy theory about
the death of Democratic National
Committee staffer Seth rich Seth rich if
you haven't been following the story was
murdered last summer and since then
there have been a number of conspiracy
theories swirling around the internet
making various claims about the
circumstances of Seth Rich's death
right-wing propaganda TV channel Fox
News has really been the only major
corporate news station talking about the
conspiracy theories and Fox News
eventually decided to retract their
statements in coverage about Seth rich
and the investigator at Fox News who had
been researching the story admitted that
there is no evidence to back up the
claims yesterday on the David Pakman
show reddit discussion forum a video was
posted of an RT segment Russian state
media segment that aired this week where
they hosted a panel of three people
having a debate about the conspiracy
theory surrounding Seth witch's death
one of the people on the panel was h.a
Goodman who was enthusiastically
supporting the conspiracy theories now
if that name sounds familiar to you a
che Goodman was on our show in January
of 2016 during the election talking
about an article he wrote where he swore
up and down that Bernie Sanders would
absolutely be the next u.s. president no
matter what I think he continued to say
that Bernie would be the nominee if not
the president
up until the day Hillary Clinton closed
the nomination and I believe even later
than that sort of arguing that any day
now
Hillary Clinton's going to be indicted
or something like that Bernie will end
up being the nominee and ultimately the
president we haven't talked that much
about Seth Rich's murder because I don't
buy into these conspiracy theories but
there's some new energy behind it and I
want to kind of take that and the Sean
Hannity thing and the RT video that I'm
going to play for you in a couple of
it's sort of as an opportunity to talk a
little bit more about what I think is
going on here as well as how certain
people and organizations have an
interest in sustaining these conspiracy
theories so the backstory in July of
2016
Seth rich a DNC employee was shot dead
near his home in Washington DC the
Washington DC police say repeatedly Seth
Rich's death was a robbery gone wrong
this took place in Bloomingdale that's
the DC neighborhood it's a neighborhood
with not an insubstantial amount of
violent crime a robbery like this would
not really be out of the ordinary in
this neighborhood in 2016 within just a
quarter-mile radius of where rich was
shot there were 24 robberies that
involved a gun that's one robbery
roughly every other week where a gun was
used right where this occurred a quarter
mile from Seth Rich's house and this
took place right near Seth witch's house
but since his death conservatives and
some mostly dogmatic Bernie Sanders fans
have tried to blame the murder on
Hillary Clinton or the DNC or maybe
WikiLeaks for knowing quote too much
about something many of them are saying
well Seth rich was actually the person
responsible for leaking the DNC emails
to WikiLeaks it wasn't Russia and that's
why he was murdered many of the people
and websites of putting out these
conspiracy theories are the same people
who hyped up those bogus pizza gate
conspiracy theories now I am a Bernie
Sanders supporter or I was in the 2016
election right I voted for Bernie
Sanders in the primary I think we need
more politicians like Bernie Sanders
I've been critical of Hillary Clinton on
this program but there are Bernie ER
Buster's and Hillary haters enamored by
this conspiracy theory because it
vilifies the DNC it vilified Hillary
Clinton and the leaks that were talking
about included emails showing that DNC
officials were disparaging Bernie
Sanders and his candidacy and trying to
tilt the primary in Hillary Clinton's
favor which we know happened in which
we've been critical of rich died right
after Hillary Clinton got the nomination
so at the time there were clearly a lot
soare and escalated feelings when it
took place
conservatives enjoy this narrative
because it makes the Democratic Party
look bad Trump supporters would love for
this to be true about Seth Rich's murder
because it would also imply or expose
that Russia wasn't responsible for the
DNC leaks which is great for the
trumpet's Julian Assange who operates
WikiLeaks also push the conspiracy
theory and we know he's shown an
interest in distancing WikiLeaks from
Russia and there was absolutely no
evidence that rich had anything to do
with the DNC leaks or that his murder
was set up by Hillary Clinton or by the
DNC all of this was based on people
saying Hillary's shady and he died right
after the leak so of course he must be
at the center of the entire thing and so
soon after this murder the noise about
the conspiracy theories sort of died
down because there was no evidence until
two weeks ago people start talking once
again about Seth Rich's murder because a
private investigator told the local DC
Fox News station that he and someone at
the FBI had evidence of connections
between Seth which and WikiLeaks
immediately right-wing outlets jump all
over this Fox News
Breitbart the blaze who immediately put
out their own stories about what the
private investigator said but then later
that same day the private investigator
says oops sorry I misspoke I don't
actually have evidence of rich being
connected to WikiLeaks but someone at
the FBI told me about it not a direct
quote but roughly what this investigator
said the private investigator explained
to CNN that he thought Fox News had the
evidence and that he was just giving a
preview of what Fox News would
eventually report the investigator said
I only got that from the reporter at Fox
News
however Fox News also didn't have
evidence Fox News was reporting on the
evidence they believed the investigator
was claiming to have it's a circle with
no actual evidence so now the only
evidence of there being a connection
between Seth rich and WikiLeaks is that
a private investigator said someone at
the FBI told that's why Fox News
retracted everything DC police say that
the assertions put forward by the
investigator are unfounded
the FBI has said it was never part of
the investigation
so maybe Seth rich had something to do
with WikiLeaks and the DNC planned his
murder but like all other conspiracy
theories whether it's the moon landing
being faked or Illuminati or whatever we
have to go off of what evidence we have
and the simplest explanation Occam's
razor and right now there really isn't
any evidence or anything pointing to it
being true however check out this
segment introduced by Peter Lavelle on
RT who is a known Russian puppet I mean
look up the history of Peter Lavelle
check out the segment done on RT and
they invited HJ Goodman to participate
in this hello and welcome to crosstalk
where all things are considered I'm
Peter Lavelle on July 10th 2016 DNC
staffers sets rich was murdered in
Washington DC was rich the source who
provided WikiLeaks with DNC's internal
emails some have speculated this was the
reason for his murder if true what he
comes of the mantra Russia did it yeah
so the guy in the debate arguing in
favor of the conspiracy is once again a
che Goodman who has a career as a
columnist basically exclusively catering
to the Bernie or bust crowd that's how a
che Goodman has become popular look at
his track record in terms of his YouTube
subscriptions I have no personal problem
with this guy I've interviewed him he's
offered to come back on the show which
we have not taken him up on he spent the
entire election vilifying hillary
clinton in saying she should be
prosecuted because of the email server
i'm just asking you to weigh the
evidence inspect the people peddling the
narrative and what their motivations
might be the people pushing this
conspiracy theory seem to be exclusively
people acting either on the behalf of
the Russian government far right-wingers
people on the alt-right Trump supporters
or people who just hate Hillary
and again Seth Rich's family has said
stop
Seth rich was not involved in this you
are making it worse for us Seth witches
family is saying the conspiracy theories
are really bad from them this is
different from the Trump Russia scandal
that is a story and a scandal in a
million different ways
everything would set rich is speculative
and hypothetical am I wrong
let me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman